buenos días pues estupor e indignación
en la unión europea tras este atentado
en mi andar todos los presidentes de las
en situaciones europeas han condenado de
forma enérgica este nuevo movimiento del
ejército el presidente del consejo
europeo charles michel y también el jefe
de la diplomacia europea de burrell han
pedido la liberación inmediata de todos
los detenidos entre ellos la nobel de la
paz aung san suu live y recuerdan que
debe respetarse el camino a la
democracia iniciado en el país en 2011
la presidenta de la comisión europea
ursula von der leyen ha asegurado que el
gobierno del país debe volver a volver a
sus funciones de acuerdo con la
constitución del país y las elecciones
del pasado noviembre además el
presidente el parlamento europeo david
se ha sol y ha asegurado que toda la
institución está unida así como todos
los países europeos en una condena al
golpe perpetrado en mianmar aún así
precisamente el parlamento europeo y
retiró el galardón del premio sajarov
aung san suu kyi
y el genocidio según la onu de la
minoría de los rohingyas hace tres años